a press conference and our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates is also in
Brussels a very busy day Sam what is the
latest
well we're waiting as you say to find
out what was concluded by the 30 or so
NATO leaders who've been meeting this
morning Boris Johnson opposite president
macron of France uh Joe Biden of the U.S
and Olive Schultz of Germany to find out
whether or not the NATO alliance is
delivering uh what president zielinski
asked for in that passionate address
that you heard some of just now now what
zelenski said was quite important he
didn't reiterate that call we understand
for a no-fly zone instead he asked for
very specific equipment one percent of
your planes one percent of your tanks is
what he asked for in a video address
with the NATO leaders now Boris Johnson
told us this morning that Britain is
already stepping up to the plate 6 000
more weapons uh just under 100 million
pounds additional aid for Ukraine and he
very much having spoken to president
zielinski only yesterday wants to put
the pressure on other Western leaders to
do more uh some Western leaders are more
reluctant than others particularly when
it comes to sanctions uh Boris Johnson
making clear today that he's going after
the as it were militia Army of President
Putin the Wagner group now they are
thought to be the individuals the
military group military force going
after president zielinski personally uh
Boris Johnson will call on other world
leaders to increase their sanctions as
well has it worked well that's exactly
what we're hoping to find out about when
we get to the press conference led by
Jen sultanburg the UN the NATO Secretary
General which should be starting uh
anytime soon
and we will go to it live when it does
begin Sam coats for now thank you so
much let's go to Ukraine and speak to
Sky Sally Lockwood who's in the Viv in
the west of the country and sadly many
years there no doubt we'll be listening
in to what NATO has to announce uh any
minute now
uh in the west one assume
from
the refugees that we've spoken to here
at levieve train station in Western
Ukraine they have far bigger things to
worry about we've just spoken to a
family who've arrived here from the
southern city of mariopol which of
course has been devastated in the last
few weeks three generations of women
from one family a grandmother a mother
and a granddaughter they are absolutely
exhausted we're talking about people
who've been without power without food
largely for weeks now and a lot of them
have been without Internet it's not
until they've been they've got here
they've got outside of Mario Paul and
managed to get to somewhere safe that
they've even been able to understand the
sort of thing that's going on that the
capital Kiev hasn't fallen as so many
assumed would happen at the beginning of
this war
and so I think the diplomacy that's
going on in Brussels today well hugely
important we're talking about a country
that's been through immense trauma in
the last month a quarter of the country
have been made homeless and certainly I
think right now survival is their
primary concern we also spoke to a
family from her son a city in the north
of Ukraine a mother who's arrived here
with her three children and she did say
though that she would like to see more
Western support in terms of closing the
Skies over Ukraine as people have have
come to describe it that no-fly zone
that president zielinski has called on
NATO to impose time and time again and
why is that well well the ground
offensive may have stalled here by
Russian troops it certainly failed in in
many areas it's not been the ground
offensive that President Putin I'm sure
imagined Russian forces haven't even
made it inside the capital Kiev yet and
indeed in some areas Ukrainian forces
are actually
retaken ground but airstrikes are what
is concerning people the most here in
Ukraine now you just need to look at
that southern city of mariopol which has
been absolutely
devastated a humanitarian disaster
unfolding in the south of the country
there the bombings described as war
crimes but one thing that I should also
mention is that we haven't yet had an
air raid siren today and I I don't
believe we had one last night either the
train station here in leviv and in
Western Ukraine which has seen tens of
thousands of families passing through it
in search of safety in recent weeks is
far quieter today there certainly seems
to be perhaps less panic in Ukraine
perhaps they've seen that the Russian
Advance has stalled has failed there is
certainly a sense of confidence here
despite the chaos despite the trauma and
all these millions of people who've been
made homeless by this war there is a
sense of confidence that Ukraine will
come through this the big Quest question
is at what cost
Sally Lockwood thank you so much
a senior Russian Diplomat has told Sky
News that Russia retains the right to
use nuclear weapons if provoked by NATO
Dimitri Polansky Russia's Deputy
ambassador to the UN also said the
country was not committing war crimes in
Ukraine despite the mounting evidence
here's our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner
this is one of very few places left in
New York where this man would still be
welcome it's here at the Russian mission
to the UN where its leading diplomats
write their speeches where they work out
how on Earth to defend the indefensible
Vladimir Putin's personal spokesperson
said that Russia retains the right to
use nuclear weapons and to defend the
country whatever that may be from
whatever invented if Russia is provoked
by NATO if Russia is attacked by NATO I
don't know so we are we are nuclear
power
why not you think that's a legitimate
thing to be saying though I don't think
it's the right thing to be saying but
it's not the right thing to
um to threaten Russia and to try to
interfere so when you're dealing with
the nuclear power of course you have to
calculate all the possible outcomes of
of your behavior that's what I'm going
to say but Russia committing more crimes
in Ukraine I don't think we're
committing war crimes in Ukraine of
course it's not up to me to to assess
I'm not there you're not there you're
looking at the videos you're looking at
the the uh many of videos who are
considered to be fake news are you
saying that that civilian homes
playgrounds hospitals theaters have not
been targeted by Russia they were not
targeted and you know it's very well we
said from the very beginning that our
military is not the threat for civilian
population Ukraine can I show you what
the U.S believes is evidence of war
crimes these are pictures taken by our
colleagues Associated Press Independent
News site these are Apartments
on fire in Mario Paul hit by Russian
missiles how do you know it's Russian
missiles
because there is a self-defense this is
your suggestion that the ukrainians
it can it can it can easily come from
Ukraine from the center of the city it
happened in harkov it happened in
mariupal because they have their own
missile launchers and a lot of cases
that I know are reported from Ukrainian
missiles themselves Ambassador with
respect I think that's preposterous the
idea that this man of this amount of
Destruction I think it's quite it's
quite logical it's not preposterous
Mr poliansky may not believe Russia is
guilty of war crimes but the U.S says
they are the international criminal
court will ultimately decide but with
every wild claim being made by its
diplomats Russia becomes increasingly
isolated on the world stage Martha
Kellner Sky News New York
there let's get the latest analysis of
the situation on the ground in Ukraine
General Sir Richard Baron sir joins me
now General Richard very uh good
afternoon to you and and of course NATO
are meeting as we speak so we just
wanted to start with a little snapshot
here of the Ukraine the NATO members uh
in blue and just uh ask the question
what's probably top of the agenda in the
discussions that they've been having
over the last few hours so this is an
emergency meeting to talk about Ukraine
and there are there are two important
Dimensions to this conversation the most
important in the longer term is how NATO
now remobilizes itself to deal with
Russia under President Putin in a way
that is the most significant change
since the end of the Cold War in 1990
and the second thing they're going to do
just as important is talk about NATO
supports to Ukraine in terms of more
sanctions and Military Support on the
topic of military support if we just
dive in a little bit closer but still
with the the NATO neighbors clearly in
shot some announcements that have
started to come out some that are
expected in terms of reinforcements yes
so NATO is going to affirm today it's
going to deploy four more battle groups
it has battery groups already deployed
across nato in one each to Slovakia
Hungary Romania and Bulgaria and they're
a sign of NATO assurance and a signal
that article 5 remains in Violet uh now
let's dive in a little bit to get some
perspectives of what's going on on the
ground in Ukraine first of all a focus
dive on Kiev itself and we have heard
relatively encouraging stories of some
Successful counter-attacks by Ukrainian
forces in and around Kiev are those
significant generals Richard so so they
are significant but they're very small
scale so we know of successful Ukrainian
contracts for example in European and
Butcher and also actually to the east of
Kiev and these are very small tactical
actions but they are indicative of the
Russian forces are not breaking into
Kiev and indeed in many places are
moving back a little and starting to
build defensive positions and that feels
like another signal of this evolving
stalemate Let's uh talk about that cell
mate if we zoom out and look at uh all
of uh Ukraine we've been talking that
these red shaded areas uh the land that
Russia has seized haven't changed
drastically over the last week the
fourth week of this war the stalemate is
is that a very good thing uh for Ukraine
or does it get Russia time to to refuel
both literally and metaphorically well
both of those things are are true I
think is is I think the signs are right
now that the Russian campaign in its
current construction is not capable of
taking much more ground and we're
beginning to see Russia dig in these
defensive positions which would indicate
that it realizes that that does not mean
that that will be the outcome because
Russia is moving reinforcements from
across Russia both men and material in
order to unlock that stalemate but we're
seeing not much movement around Kiev
we're seeing the battle for Mario poll
which I I we imagine they will in the
end uh break we have not seen the
significant movement towards Odessa that
we were forecasting a week ago but we
couldn't rule it out and we are
concerned about Russian forces moving
from the North and the South of the
country once Mario Paul is concluded in
order to try and circle the Ukrainian
forces in the in the donbass but what
this begins to feel like is a war
confined to the east of Ukraine except
for continuing air and missile attacks
in the West on the supply lines but this
is not the war Russia intended to have
General Sir Richard Baron sir thanks so
much for that summary of what's going on
on the ground on this fourth week of the
war
the Ukrainian government says seven
humanitarian corridors have been agreed
today but there's still no safe passage
out of the city of mariopol tens of
thousands of people are trapped there
without food water or medicine and life
is extremely difficult our correspondent
Sally Lockwood spoke to one mother who
has managed to escape
the city of mariopol is almost totally
destroyed in its ashes or at least a
hundred thousand people trapped and
trying to stay alive but it's feared
they could be far more than that
uh let's interrupt that and go live now
to Brussels uh that NATO press
conference with Secretary General yens
stoltenberg starting good afternoon we
have just finished an extraordinary
Summit of NATO leaders to address the
biggest threat to our security in our
generation President Putin's war against
Ukraine
the people of Ukraine are assisting with
courage and determination
fighting for the freedom and for their
future we stand with them
addressed us with an
impassioned message
thanking NATO allies for the significant
support we are providing
and stressing the vital importance of
even more military assistance
today Natalie disagreed that we must and
will provide further support to Ukraine
we will continue to impose unprecedented
costs on Russia
and we will reinforce Allied deterrence
and defense
leaders approved our four new battle
groups in Bulgaria Hungary Romania and
Slovakia
these are in addition to the four
already in the Baltic countries and
Poland
so we have eight multinational NATO bat
groups now from the Baltic Sea to the
Black Sea
across Europe there are 100
000 U.S troops
supporting NATO efforts
and European allies and Canada have also
stepped up
we have 40 000 forces on the direct NATO
command mostly in the East and part of
the alliance
backed by major air enabled power
including an unprecedented fog carrier
strike groups from The High North to the
Mediterranean
today NATO leaders agreed to reset our
returns and defense for the longer term
to face a new security reality
online
we will have substantially more forces
in the eastern part of the lions at
higher redness with more pre-positioned
equipment and supplies
in the air
we will deploy more Jets and strengthen
our integrated air and missile defense
at sea
we will have a carrier Stark groups
submarines and significant numbers of
combat ships on a persistent basis
we will also strengthen our cyber
defenses and enhance our exercises
focusing on Collective events and
interoperability
I expect we will decide on the details
at our next Summit in Madrid in June
today Allah leaders also agreed to
provide further support to Ukraine
helping to uphold their fundamental
right to self-defense
allies are also equipping Ukraine with
significant military supplies
including anti-tank and air defense
systems and drones
which are proving highly effective
as well as substantial financial and
humanitarian Aid
today we agreed to do more
including cyber security assistance and
equipment to help Ukraine protect
against biological chemical radiological
and nuclear threats
this could include detection
protection and medical supplies as well
as training for the decontamination and
crisis management
we are determined to do all we can to
support Ukraine and I welcome the
concrete offers of assistance made by
allies today
at the same time
we have a responsibility to ensure the
conflict does not escalate further
because this would be even more
dangerous and more devastating
allies agreed that we must also increase
our support for other partners at risk
from Russia and from at risk from
Russian threats and interference
including Georgia and Bosna and
Herzegovina
working together and with the European
Union we must help them uphold their
sovereignty and strengthen their
resilience
we also addressed the beijing's role in
the crisis today Allied leaders called
on China to refrain from supporting
Russia's war effort
China must not provide economic or
military support for the Russian
invasion instead Beijing should use its
significant influence on Russia and
promote
an immediate peaceful resolution
Allah's also agree that Belarus must
stop acting as an accomplice to Putin's
invasion
at today's meeting leaders reaffirmed
strong our strong commitment to NATO's
open door policy under article 10 of the
Washington treaty
NATO enlargement has been an historic
success
spreading democracy freedom and
prosperity across Europe
one month since the start of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine NATO security
environment has fundamentally changed
for a long haul
and we are responding
but security but security does not come
for free and doing war will cost more
so NATO leaders agreed to read double
efforts to meet the defense investment
pledge we made in 2014.
allies will submit additional plans on
how to meet the pledge in time for the
Madrid Summit in June
and I welcome that the number of allies
today announced plans for significant
increases in defense spending
at this Dangerous Time transatlantic
are vital Europe and North America are
standing and will continue to stand
strong together in NATO I mean that I'm
ready to take your questions
and then
hi Mr Secretary General thank you
um president zielinski and his address
to Nato accused Russia of deploying
phosphorus Munitions I'm wondering
whether NATO has seen evidence of that
and what your response is or would be
and then I'm wondering did you discuss
during this meeting a permanent basing
of forces in any of these countries such
as the baltics and abandoning the
nato-russia founding Act
so we are we set the NATO's returns and
defense for the long term
uh with more troops with more air assets
and more Maritime capabilities we have
already increased our presence in the
East and today we decided on four new
battle groups and the leaders agreed to
toss our military commanders to provide
options
for a long-term reset of our presence
our military posture in the eastern part
of the alliance and across the whole
Alliance details will be then decided at
our Summit in June but that comes on top
of what we have already done so this is
uh long term we are prepared for Long
Haul because
we can always today say that that the
Russian invasion President Putin's
invasion of Ukraine
has changed our security environment for
the long term it's a new reality it's uh
it's uh it's a new normal and NATO is
responding for a long term we have seen
very credible reports about
the use of
the use of the military force against
civilians and of course this is of great
concern for all NATO allies
you're taking my question how to believe
NATO will respond if China begins to
support Russia economically and perhaps
with military supplies and also do you
believe that there's a role to play for
NATO when it comes to alleviating energy
costs and I'm talking about speaking
directly to Saudi Arabia and other OPEC
producers thank you
so NATO allies all coordinating their
efforts when it comes to also energy
security and it was also addressed in
the meeting today
to step up supplies to diversify
sources of supply and uh and also also
to reduce dependence on supplies from
from Russia and and later on today I
also participate in the G7 meeting and
of course in different Frameworks G7
working with the EU there are different
formats where NATO allies address the
need to strengthen energy security and
reduce dependence on on on on Russian
oil and and gas our message to China is
that they should join the rest of the
world and clearly condemn the brutal war
against Ukraine and not support
Russia neither with uh with economic
support or of course not with Military
Support
to go to interface Ukraine late in the
second row
the general news agency interfox Ukraine
I would like to ask you if polish
leadership would add the table today for
discussion the proposal to send
peacekeeping mission to Ukraine and if
yes what kind of discussion it was and
is there is some conclusion thank you
as we discussed the wide range of issues
and and the message is that we have to
stand United and also that we need to
provide support to Ukraine but at the
same time we have a responsibility
to ensure that this conflict do not
become a full-fledged war between NATO
and Russia and and that's also reason
why allies are Medicaid that we will not
deploy troops on the ground in in
Ukraine because the only way to do that
is to be prepared to engage in full
conflict with Russian troops okay
Financial Times
thank you very much Secretary General
congratulations on your annual extension
um you said in the statement that allies
agree to enhance preparedness and
Readiness for chemical biological
radiological and nuclear threats is that
based on credible intelligence that
those threats could be imminent and how
does the alliance strengthen its
protection against those threats thank
you
you're concerned partly because we see
the rhetoric and we see that Russia is
trying to create some kind of pretext
accusing Ukraine United States NATO
allies for preparing to use a chemical
and biological weapons and we have seen
before that this
way of accusing others is actually a way
to create to create the pretext for do
the same themselves and and of course
their accusations against Ukraine and
NATO allies are absolutely false
um any use of chemical weapons will
totally change the nature of the
conflict it will be a blatant violation
of international law and
it will have a wide spread consequences
and of course be extremely dangerous
it will affect the people in Ukraine but
there's also a risk that will have a
direct effect on people living in NATO
countries because
we can see contamination we can see the
spread of
chemical agents or biological weapons
into our countries
we also know that Russia has used
chemical agents against its own
opposition and they have used it on NATO
territory in Salisbury before and we
also know that Russia has facilitated
supported
the Assad regime in Syria when they used
chemical weapons against their own
population so this just highlights the
importance of ending this war
immediately because this is a dangerous
situation
and therefore we impose the sanctions
that we therefore we support uh Ukraine
um allies agreed to supply equipment to
help Ukraine protect against chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
threats this could include
detection equipment protection and
medical support as well as training for
the contamination and crisis management
we are also enhancing allies
preparedness and Readiness for chemical
and biological and nuclear threats our
top military commander General Walters
has activated NATO's chemical biological
radiological and nuclear defense
elements and allies are deploying
additional chemical and biological and
nuclear defenses to reinforce our
existing and new backing groups so we
are taking measures both to support
Ukraine and also to defend ourselves go
to Al Jazeera
Secretary General James Bays from Al
Jazeera president zielinski when he
addressed you recalled the fact he first
spoke to you a month ago and he says he
didn't get clear answers so this time he
asked you specifically for one percent
of all your tanks for one percent of all
your aircraft for multi-launch Rocket
systems anti-ship weapons and means of
air defense a very specific list what is
your clear answer
we all listened very carefully to
president zelensky and many of the
leaders in the room have had contact
with him over these weeks I also spoke
with him and under the Ukraine defense
means participated in our defense
ministerial meeting last week we
listened carefully and of course we took
note of his very compassionate message
to all NATO allies
NATO allies provide significant support
to Ukraine
and we provide also little weapons
Advanced systems and also systems that
help them to shoot down planes and
attack
battle tanks with anti-tank weapons and
many other types of uh of systems
including drones I will not go into the
details of the exact type of systems we
are deploying this close contact between
NATO allies and Ukraine but what I can
say is that allies do what they can to
support Ukraine with weapons so Ukraine
can defend themselves self-defense is a
right and Shine the new and Charter at
the same time we have a responsibility
to prevent this conflict from becoming a
full-fledged war in Europe involving not
only Ukraine and Russia but NATO allies
and Russia that will be more dangerous
and more devastating thing and and I
think we have to be honest about that
and that's exactly what we have been in
our meeting today and also what do I say
to you in the press conference now
well what we do is that we are
delivering a lot of uh equipment and
that is an answer but I would not go
into the the details I don't think
that's the wise for operational reasons
if I listed exactly what and when and
how we are delivering uh essential
equipment to Ukraine a NATO allies have
stepped up and it's essential for the
progress they have been able to make in
the fight against uh the invading
Russian forces thank you very much
colleagues I know there are many
questions I'm afraid the Secretary
General needs to go to the G7 meeting
but there will be other briefings
throughout the day thank you so much
thank you
that was the Secretary General of NATO
against stoltenberg let's just uh sum up
some of the key points he just made
first and foremost he said at the top we
stand with Ukraine he agreed he said
that the NATO members in their meeting
just now had agreed that they must
provide further support to Ukraine and
of course touched on that point that we
discussing earlier in the show that the
leaders have now approved those four new
battle groups uh to be stationed in
Slovakia Hungary Romania and Bulgaria
and did mention there that this wasn't
just temporary aiming to reset NATO's
defense and security position for the
long term so there's about 100 000 NATO
troops across Europe right now and
mentioned that various individual member
states of NATO are adding their own
further help during that by the way I
should also just mention that we've just
had a statement from President Biden
that was released during that press
conference one line that stands out out
on that is that NATO is as strong and
United as it has ever been he outlines
uh the uh Aid to Ukraine the defensive
Aid to Ukraine that the US has been
involved in more than a billion dollars
in new security assistance he says
anti-aircraft systems anti-armor weapons
drones and millions of rounds of
ammunition that of course over the
course of the last month not a new
billion dollars announced today and he
says he welcomes the steps by many other
allies to provide defensive support to
Ukraine and together we NATO are
committed to identifying additional
equipment including air defense systems
to help Ukraine he like Jen soldenberg
just then uh also mentioned further
announcements expected and that they're
planning towards ahead of the next NATO
Summit uh in June just going back uh to
some of the comments from Jens
stolenberg he also said they have seen
credible reports of military force
against civilians in Ukraine and
concerned by some of Russia's rhetoric
that suggests they might be preparing to
use chemical weapons he made clear that
any Russian claims or accusations that
the west or Ukraine have been using uh
chemical weapons themselves are totally
uh false he did say that any use by
Russia of chemical weapons would totally
change the nature of this war he
mentioned the risk that those types of
weapons could affect NATO countries
given the potential way that they might
spread across borders and he said he
knows that Russia has used those sorts
of weapons in the past that was that
press conference from the NATO Secretary
General Jens stoltenberg just wrapped up
moments ago alongside some comments from
President Biden of course the NATO
meetings may have started to wrap up we
still have a GPS 7 meeting we still have
an EU meeting so lots more going on on
the ground there in in Brussels
throughout the rest of this day
one of the first Ukrainian refugees to
be matched with a family in England
under the government's homes for Ukraine
scheme is spending her first day in
Bedford